welcome to the new old review yo sauce
for everything anime and manga except
for you know right now because this
channel has recently passed an
incredible 30 thousand subscribers and
as a result I would like to do a bit of
Q&A with all a few wonderful viewers so
basically if you'd like to ask me a
question it can be about essentially
anything yet the stuff I cover on the
channel or other anime or manga or
anything that's not anime or manga just
whatever then please do post it in the
comment section below
the only real rule I have is that please
limit it to one question per user I'll
just say right now that I won't be
answering comments with multiple
questions so choose wisely or choose
foolishly they don't brilliant mind
either way and basically what's going to
happen is that I'll be answering these
questions in a special question corner
segment at the end of all of my future
videos so stay tuned and hopefully your
inquiry will be seen on screen the DA
that's about it for this once again if
you want to ask me a question drop it in
the comments below and thank you so so
much for making this amazing subscriber
milestone possible this has been the New
World review and I'll see you next time